welcome to the ongoing saga that is the
executive session for SB
um 14. I make a motion
to
adopt amendment number
2023-2074h second Mr chair
um
any discussion necessary I think we
representative Bolden
so is this I'm sorry is this the exact
same wording as 473 it is this is the
exact same wording as past the house
and
we compared them word for word there's
been no changes at all thank you you're
welcome
um having
at risk of seeing um something about a
horse
um I'll ask the court to call the roll
emotional Flora is adopting the
amendment
Vice chair Rhodes
representative Pratt
oh okay
um and neither is representative scitec
representative Melville
yes it's not Melville oh sorry
Melvin
um representative Jan van
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes representative
gathright
representative muse no representative
Bolden yes representative
goalie
no representative Murphy no
representative Newman no the clerk votes
yes
representative Newell yes
representative Brennan no
representative wheeler
nay
chairman Roy
Geralds yes
11 years seven days
motion to adopt carries
I make a motion to author pass as
amended second Mr chair and ask the
clerk to call the rule
foreign
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Melvin
representative janvin
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tensar yes
representative Guthrie
representative Muse yes representative
Bolton yes representative goalie
no
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative Brennan
yes representative wheeler chairman Roy
terrible GS
17 years one day
is there an objection to consent on the
one
no objection to consent it'll go on a
consent calendar although I don't
anticipate probably staying there but we
can try
with that I close the executive session
for real this time
everybody run before somebody tells us
that we have to do something else